Ми приготували "тривожну валізку" наприкінці січня на випадок, якщо доведеться втікати.
Усе це було дуже емоційно.
Я провела багато часу в гіпермаркеті  - пригадую це відчуття, коли стоїш перед полицею і робиш вибір,
що купити, аби мати необхідні продукти на випадок війни.
Ольга втекла від війни в Україні до Німеччини. Так само, як ще 600 тисяч українців.
Багато з них змушені були покинути не лише свої домівки, друзів і рідних, а й нерідко добре оплачувану роботу.
Я працювала в компанії, яка імпортувала з Німеччини мастила для двигунів для продажу в Україні.
Моя посада - фінансовий директор. Але тепер я тут - бухгалтер і маю хорошу можливість дати охолонути мозку з огляду на все, що відбувається.
А ще це хороша нагода бути корисною тут, у Німеччині.
Поліна та Маша також через війну опинилися у ФРН. Машу війна застала у відпустці, під час короткої поїздки в Барселону.
Поліна разом з 11-річною сестрою прибула до Німеччини із Західної України.
Тепер обоє працюють в Job-Aid-Ukraine, де допомагають знайти роботу іншим втікачам від війни з України. Завдання не з легких.
Ідеться, звісно, про мову, яка є важливою для багатьох вакансій. Це має бути німецька, але багато хто не володіє ані німецькою, ані англійською.
Тож це, гадаю, головна проблема. Але іноді ще й важко знайти біженцю роботу за фахом,
тому що здобуті і чинні в Україні професійні кваліфікації не цілком рівноцінні німецьким.
Платформа з пошуку роботи для українців працює вже сім тижнів. За цей час вдалося знайти понад 5000 вакансій для українських біженців по всій Європі.
Маркус Дікманн - співініціатор проєкту. Ідея виникла відразу після початку повномасштабної війни в Україні і була втілена за п'ять днів і ночей.
Пропозиції роботи надходять не лише з Європи, а й з цілого світу.
Найбільший виклик - те, що ми чітко розуміємо: до нас прибули висококваліфіковані чоловіки й жінки,
і ми повинні знайти їм хорошу роботу, яка б відповідала їхній кваліфікації.
Тобто щоб експерт чи експертка з інформаційних технологій не йшли працювати доглядальниками, а знайшли правильну роботу.
А хороший доглядальник, звісно, отримав роботу з догляду за людьми. Оце наш найбільший виклик.
Ірина вже два місяці працює в Берліні. Роботу в ресторані вона знайшла ще під час втечі разом з чоловіком і сином до Німеччини.
Лише опинившись у безпеці, вона забрала сюди решту своєї родини. Для 29-річної жінки це велика відповідальність.
Це дуже-дуже важливо, бо ми удвох забезпечуємо родину із семи осіб: це чоловікова мама, його тьотя, прабабуся, сестра.
У берлінській мережі ресторанів "Дача" працюють 190 людей. Більшість із них володіють українською чи російською мовою.
Ще до війни підприємство цілеспрямовано шукало працівників в Україні.
Нині робота тут значно полегшує життя українцям на кшталт Ірини, які не знають німецької мови.
У ресторанній галузі в Німеччині нині багато вільних вакансій на тлі покращення ситуації з пандемією коронавірусу.
Це можливість заробити на життя для біженців з України. Утім, для багатьох робота - не лише джерело прибутку.
Робота допомагає усвідомити, що життя триває. І так, у нас проблеми, величезні проблеми, ми в біді, але треба жити.
Нам треба жити далі. Треба сподіватися, що колись війна закінчиться.
Це дуже важливо.
Адже ці українські жінки хочуть повернутися на батьківщину, аби відбудовувати свою країну.